remember Ari Abraham the mysterious NBA
Insider on Twitter who guaranteed that
Kawhi was going to the Lakers and had
everyone fooled Kawai was coming off a
historic Championship with the Raptors
and it opted to test out free agency top
reporters such as wolves and Sams had no
information on kawhi's impending
decisions but an unknown Twitter account
claimed to have all the answers just 22
years old at the time no one knew why
Ari Abraham was gaining so much
attention however years ago at age 16 he
found out that Dwight Howard was meeting
with the Houston Rockets at the Beverly
Wilshire Hotel it became his biggest
scoop suddenly he was seen as a reliable
source and grew his page from 20 total
followers to 38 000. everything changed
on July 1st so he reported that the
Clippers were out of the sweepstakes for
Leonard and that he had already made up
his mind but Leonard shocked the World
by deciding to sign with the Clippers
that summer along with Paul George
Abraham's tweets ended up being wrong
and even though he tried to explain
himself on various Outlets he
disappeared from Twitter and we haven't
really heard from him since maybe Kawhi
was set to go to the Lakers and ended up
changing his mind or maybe we should all
be careful about the reporters we
trusted on Twitter